те про що останнім часом Так активно
обговорювалося в ЗМІ як чутки так і
сталося культового Генерала Валерія
заложного звільнили з посади чим
запам'ятається українцям харизматичний
головнокомандувач
що відомо про залужного
50тирічний Валерій залужний родом із
Житомирщини він став першим головкомом
ЗСУ який Не навчався у радянських
військових вишах а закінчував українські
після 2 14 року він дослужився до
заступника командувача угруповання на
Донбасі а в 2021 Володимир Зеленський
запропонував залужному очолити
ЗСУ популярність залізного Генерала під
час повномасштабного вторгнення залужний
став символом українського спротиву
західні партнери України визнають його
військовий талант а в Україні про
залужного складають пісні його фото на
картинах чашках і
футболках хоча залуж не рідко дає
інтерв'ю його не можна назвати закритою
людиною наприклад він часто публікує в
соцмережах фото з дружиною Оленою А це
незвично для
Генерала А ще охочі зустрічаються зі
знаменитостями припреміром
фектувальницею Ольгою Харлан
письменником Сергієм жоданом опитування
зокрема кміс у грудні 2023 року показали
що залужному довіряють майже 90%
українців як Володимиру зеленському дещо
більше
60ти конфлікт із
Зеленським припущення про непорозуміння
у відносинах президента та
головнокомандувача вперше з'явилися у
ЗМІ ще навесні 2022 року улітку ЗМІ
припускали що в офісі президента
побоюються високої довіри до головкома в
суспільстві у листопаді 2023 року
розбіжності між Зеленським і залужним
різко стали публічними
привід проблема контрнаступу залужни в
інтерв'ю та статті для британського
журналу економіст заявив про перехід
допозиційної війни та визнав невдачу
наступальних дій ЗСУ Зеленський частково
спростував його слова заявивши що
патової ситуації на фронті немає потім
президент змінював вищих офіцерів не
погоджуючи з
головнокомандувачем ще одна неоднозначна
для президента і головкома тема
залужний критикував рішення Зеленського
про зміну всіх військомів для боротьби з
корупцією він також дистанціювався від
озвученої президентом нібито запрошеної
військовими цифри мобілізації
півмільйона Хто якщо не
залужний новим головнокомандувачем ЗСУ
президент призначив генерал-полковника
Олександра сирського за словами
Зеленського вінчийб більш досвідчений
український командувач і має успішний
досвід захисту провів Київську оборонну
операцію Він також має успішний досвід
наступу операція по звільненню
Харківщини залужного в президенти
залужний очолив українське військо у
складний час і мав Як успіхи так і
невдачі у статті для економіста залуджни
самокритично визнав помилку здивувався
тому що великі втрати Росії не зупинили
війну це рідкісний випадок для
керівництво України досі триває
розслідування обставин швидкої окупації
Росією українського півдня ЗМІ писали що
слідство розмовляло про це зокрема із
залужним
чи піде залужни у президенти є
припущення що нібито саме приховане
бажання головкома зайняти крісло глави
держави стало причиною розбіжностей із
Зеленським Валерій залужний ніколи не
заявляв про політичні амбіції але Якби
він їх проявив то Якщо вірити
опитуванням розраховувати на підтримку
чималої частини українського
суспільствай час я вірю в кожного з вас
і в нашу
перемогу